hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become hi I'm Jenna so and welcome
back to another crazy workout challenge
today we're good to complete 1000 squat
and lunge challenge so your legs will be
on fire there will be a total of 10
exercises for each exercise we want to
complete 50 repetitions and we want to
repeat all the workouts again twice
through are you ready so let's start
with some dynamic stretches okay so I
just want you to spread your legs wide
apart and just twist and just reach good
so just reach up feel your hamstrings
being stretched out and just look the
opposite side good keep going and feel
your back being stretched out as well
few more keep your leg straight all
right last one and come up and now I
want you to just open up your hips to
get yourself ready for the squat and
lunges so just to the side open up your
hips open point your knees out make a
huge semicircle to the side and just
feel your hips opening up good keep
going left and right
so each workout will be for 50
repetitions okay we will be doing this
together and just shake twist it a
little bit side to side and just loosen
up those hips loosen up your arms as
well very good and the good news about
this challenge is that there will be no
jumping involved so anybody can do this
challenge and take it at their own pace
your goal is to complete 1,000 at your
own timing so let's start with the first
workout which is prisoner squad or if
you want to you
can also do basic squat so Stan sugar
with a pot with your toes pointed
forward for prisoner squat place your
hands by your head and just give me easy
squat down push your butt back and back
up good so squat down and up keep your
knees soft nice and remember it's 50 so
take it easy this is your first workout
down and up and the reason why you want
to place both hands by your ears it's so
that you will keep your chest open okay
do not collapse or hunch forward this is
wrong so look forward hands by your ears
oh if you want to you can place them in
front of you choose your option nice
keep going whew whew your legs warming
up push your butt back okay push your
butt stick your butt out keep going
so push your butt back stick your butt
out your knees should not go over your
toes nice 20 more down and up beginners
if you have to you can always go half
way through okay
as you progress squat deeper
can you feel your thighs your glutes
warming up ten more nine eight seven
let's go six last five five four three
two one
first squad are done shake it out next
will be static lunge so with static
lunge Stan sugar with a putt take one
white step forward so start with your
right leg forward left leg back and just
lunge up and down 25 on each side okay
let's go down it up place your hands
just by your hips nice and easy find
your balance type in your belly sucker
Corinne look straight ahead and you
should feel the work on your right glute
keep going
point your heels I mean point your knees
down towards the floor
and keep your body in a straight line so
do
lean forward okay keep it down keep
going last five more five four three two
one ha and now we got to balance that up
left leg forward okay so step left leg
forward right leg back let's go
static lunge two three keep going four
five six seven
nice eight nine ten fifteen more all
right let's go one two three four count
with me
five six seven eight nine twenty last
five one two three four five oh all
right shake videos check it out there
are lots of different variations for
squad the next squad we want to work on
it's narrow squat typically this is
basic squad with narrow squad I want
here to keep both legs close together
with a toes pointed forward if this is
too tough you can spread it slightly
apart okay so keep both legs together
and I want you to same thing hands in
front of you go down you should feel
more work on your glutes and this is
also more challenging because you really
have to find the balance tuck your tummy
in and keep your chest up keep going
let's go fifty all right good knees
together squeeze your inner thighs as
well very good keep them close together
nice
down and up one thousand let's do this
done another squeeze your inner thighs
together squeeze the glutes as you come
up and feel the work around your legs
you're halfway there okay keep going
breathe in and out remember to keep
breathing
so in and out in and out 20 more keep
squatting do not stop right now you can
go a little less lower but do not stop
right now okay bring your butt down to
the floor drive it up with your heels up
down and up ten more let's go nine eight
seven six chest up do not cheat five
four plus three three two last one
one oh my gosh shake it out shake it out
Oh your heart rate should be pumping as
well alright next back to lunges reverse
lunge alright so stand with your feet
pointed forward shoulder width apart
I want it to take a step back with a
left leg bring it forward and now take a
step back with the right leg
so alternating between legs good and
that's - all right don't worry that's
too good keep stepping back and stepping
forward pushing up with the leading
heels up keep going push good so body up
push up with your heels push yourself
into a standing position nice push up
let's go push up take a white step back
okay ah
keep going wider step lunch both legs
should be in a 90 degree angle up keep
going
alternating reverse lunge 20 more nice
push up let's go huh you are strong okay
we were to get your legs on fire
up let's go push up nice low
let's go low let's go last ten let's go
low last eight nice
six more last four last two and one more
and up guys if you feel that do you know
what Joanna this is too easy
I want to challenge myself even more
then guess what you can lift some
weights
all right back to squad we've worked on
basic squat narrow squat now let's go
white okay super squad to work on your
inner thighs so with this squad you have
to stand why did I showed it with a pad
with a toes pointed out okay drop it
back down and push up you should feel
the stretch and the work along your
inner thighs as well as your our two
glutes good so look forward the most
common mistake is people doing this this
is wrong okay look forward squat down
and push it off another common mistake
is standing too close this is wrong as
well so step white toast points that
asked push up again with your Hughes
henceforward or by your hips
let's go home oh my god what a great way
to start Monday
down and up up and down nice keep going
haha
point your toes out guys I will stay
here all day long with you we can please
one thousand square and lunges keep
going down already dripping 20 more nice
pointy toes out push your butt back okay
push your butt back pointy toes out good
push it back
nice do your inner thigh squeeze the
inner thighs right at the top down
squeeze ten more nine
eight seven keeping it off six five four
three two last one one and up okay
curtsy lunge alright curtsy lunge helps
to work on your hips so if you find that
you know what Joanna I want to turn up
on my hips this is the area my saddlebag
I want to work on this work on more
curtsy lunges alright so same thing
stand toes pointed forward shoot it with
a pot and curtsy to the left twist it
point it back and to the right so
crossover and twist good that's two all
right keep going
point and aim to keep your body and your
face facing forward good whoa drive your
knees as close to the floor as possible
keep going
remember take your own pace breathe
breathe in and out
I feel you I can see my sweat dripping
grief through my top but you know what
our sweat is our fat crying keep going
cross over feel your hips your saddlebag
area working good twist into twist even
more nice oh my gosh oh you got this
okay you got this at the end of round
one you will get a short break
keep going nice twist
ten more eight more
six more last four down and half alright
take a short break wipe your sweat if
you need to we're going to stat squad
okay so you're going to step one leg out
to the left and another leg out to the
right okay so start in a narrow squat
position all right let's go left out
right and out good there you go
alternating between legs ah let me know
in the comments below if your legs are
on fire no jumping needed just lots of
repetitions okay keep going by now you
should be able to push and squat lower
good keep going to the side step side to
side whoo I feel you guys keep going to
the left and to the right you're halfway
there okay very good
when your legs are burning when you feel
your muscles burning that's when you
keep pushing okay
keep pushing do not stop when you're
tired you can take it easy but start
when you're done okay stop when you're
done keep going
last ten eight last four guys four more
last two and one more on the right huh
all right if you I'm losing my balance
there if you have done the few daily
challenge you will know this next move
explosive lunge okay so we want to
explode with a slight upward movement on
your front leg okay so choose one leg
let's start with your right leg forward
and give me a lunch down export up push
up and land gently that's it okay
25 on each side remember you don't have
to explode too high up small pulses
trust me you will work on them gluts up
down up and down
nice keep going whoa done it up last ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
oh my gosh one change okay right stay
with me
okay stay with me I feel your burn okay
shake it out a little bit haha look at
that this top should be covered in sweat
by the end of round one let's go left
leg forward right leg back ready
explode up good small hops okay three
keep going hah take it easy breathe in
and breathe out
down and up ten more nine eight seven
six five four three two one huh I'm
crying I'm sweating I'm feeling my heart
rate pumping two more workouts haha
you're gonna love this next one squad
pulses so in a normal setting squat
position stay low and pulse for 50 times
alright I can see my crew shaking their
heads I hope you're not shaking your
heads at home okay let's go
shoulda width apart toes pointed forward
let's go down and pass to stay low do
not come up small pulses okay stay come
on you got this really focus on your
glutes your hamstrings push your butt
back through those pulses burning
through ah keep going you're halfway
there
you got ten more nine eight seven six
five four three two one
whoa not done not done last workout this
is a combination of squat with lunges
it's a love-hate relationship I love
this workout but I have this workout
because it is still painful especially
after you have done 450 squats and
ranges alright let's go let's go let's
talk more doing ready let's start on
your left leg okay so drive your left
leg back squat down and launch back good
alright
25 on each side working mainly on your
right leg
keep going right in focusing on one side
keep your knees soft drive it ah
keep going last ten more you got this
remember you can slow down but do not
stop okay I feel your burn let's keep
going
that's five more let's go four three two
one
this soreness it is real okay one final
25 repetitions and you get a short rest
okay
we get a break after this ready look at
the stretch let's go so now drive your
right leg back okay let's go squat down
back
keep going stay focused guys
this is a last workout and I promise you
you will get a break ha ha
if you need to squat halfway ok
breathe breathe in and breathe out see
your sweat dripping but you keep going
that's ten more okay what is 10 you have
done 490 keep going last 5 more 4 3 ha -
that's one more guys come on down ah
then take a rest
ah you've done 500 squats and lunges ok
take a short break
keep it up hydrated wipe your sweat I
challenge you to complete another round
with me ok so do not go anywhere do not
pass this video take a short break and
let's continue what your sweat
I need my pink potion okay just take a
minute to breathe stretch if you need to
just relax
sometimes when you squat it's not just
your legs that are feeling sore but also
your upper body so just rotate your
shoulders okay stretch out a little bit
Oh breathe stretch it out
rotate the hips drenched in sweat all
right shake it out are you ready are you
ready let me stay here yes okay leave
your comments in the comment below tell
me you have completed 1,000 squats and
lunges alright and let's start with a
basic squat okay
then again sugar with a pad toes pointed
forward 50 repetitions this is your
final round let's go down and up choose
your option you can place your hands in
front of you or if you want a little bit
more challenge place them by your ears
or the side of your head okay keep going
squat again push your butt back look
straight at me good look straight at me
push back whoo
pizza breathing breathe in and out
down and up
good always keeping sure that your toes
are pointing forward your butt is pushed
back nice done and up henceforward 20
more
ah this should be a nice warmup
let's go last ten nine eight seven six
five four three two and one
the easy part is over guys forget about
the easy part now let's do static lunch
okay
so right leg forward left leg back 25 on
each side okay let's go down and up
point your knees down
remember do not lean forward or lean
back your body should be in an upright
position
up and down the only thing should be
moving are your knees bending up and
down keep going last ten nine eight
seven six five four three two why change
the other side okay left leg forward
right leg back okay so remember to step
wide enough not too wide but not too
narrow so take a wide step back and
let's go down and up find your balance
look straight ahead tighten your core
and up and listen to your breathing
who last 10987 come with me
six five last five come on four three
two last one down and up good job
so we have done basic now we're going to
go to narrow squat okay so remember
heels toes both legs together point it
forward push your butt back okay let's
go up and down only go as low as you can
without punching forward okay so push
your butt back hands in front of you
nice and easy huh keep both hands close
to your body nice keep going push your
butt back oh my gosh who comes up with
all these kind of crazy workout
challenges well guess what you have done
several we got challenges with me the
past month
hey new year new workout challenge for
you this time we want to burn those legs
down it up last 20 squeeze your inner
thighs together keep your knees to use
your toes together and down another keep
going haha
that's ten more nine eight seven six
push five four three
speed it up push up with the heels to
one good job you know the drill
reverse lunge okay so alternating
between left and right leg so step
forward
toes pointed forward start with the left
leg back one and two good keep going
and again remember your body should be
upright use your heels to push yourself
forward all right do not compromise on
your core
this involves your core strength as well
so use your heels tighten your core push
up and stand straight up
reverse lunge good job keep going down
and up breathe find that balance
guys you are halfway there okay halfway
there let's keep going ah sweat is
dripping right into my eyes wahoo
who's with me who's still playing this
video who's with me
who's still doing this workout keep
going
last ten plus eight six come on last
four last two one on each side if you
need to if you really need to I wanted
to give this chance to to pause the
video wipe your sweat drink some water
and join me back in this workout okay so
basic narrow wide squat okay I'll sumo
squat like how I like to call it then
why should I be the pot toes point out
push your butt back okay
remember this is wrong take a wider step
all right let's go we're gonna inner
thighs
go low whew inner thighs stretched out
and then push back up keep going
the more you pace your breathing the
better you will be at your workout and
the longer you will be able to sustain
your workout going squat low push-up
remember you're bending from the knees
not from your waist
haha I feel you okay
come on keep going squad forward post
point it out down 20 more down and up
hands forward okay relax your upper body
whoo push up fast up slow down fast up
ten more keep going five more five come
together four three two last one down
and up
okay curtsy lunge I would say it is one
of the best lunges for women to really
work on your hips just now we work on
the inner thighs now we want to work on
the outer thighs as well as these
saddlebag area okay so curtsy lunge
catch your breath
stand sugar with the pot all right twist
lunch to the side up and lunge to the
side
good that's two good crossover look
straight ahead okay so minimize the
twisting on your upper body twist from
your hips let's keep going do not look
at the countdown right now okay just
keep going you are more than halfway
there for this second circuit down and
up
breathe twist
drive the knees down okay push up twenty
more ten more on each side
up push up there you go drive it up your
legs are strong ladies your legs are
strong drive it up down last ten that's
eight six last four last - come on one
and the other side and done rest take a
short break
okay wipe it so I drink some water
you have four more workouts after this
okay
four more exercises so take this time to
breathe keep yourself hydrated catch
your breath
bring your heart rate down a little bit
all right ready huh next step squat so
we're stepping to the left and to the
right oh I need to maintain my energy
level keep it up keep it high up keep
your heart rate going
sweat it out and you will feel damn good
okay let's go to the side left and right
left and right nice and easy okay
breathe in breathe out on the way up
good keep going take a step if you want
to you can always speed it up a little
bit okay
beginners slow it down good keep going
nice look straight ahead
find your focus look at me look straight
into the camera that's your focus last
20
ha down go low go home come on let's go
low nine eight seven six five four three
two last one and up oh my god no we're
getting into all those small pulses okay
he starts with explosive lunge all right
we're not stopping the workout I'm doing
this workout with you I can feel your
heart rate I can relate to you let's go
right leg forward left leg back explore
it on your right leg okay small hops
good just small lift your heels and it
toes off the floor and keep pushing
drive it down push it up small nice off
the floor drop it up nine eight seven
six five four three two last one
ah ah left leg okay left leg Oh
let's do this focus left side right leg
back let's go one two three four five
six seven twenty five eight nine ten
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 20 1 2 3 4 5 ok last
two exercises oh this is a love-hate
relationship squat pulses ok
do not come up okay it's got puzzles in
to stay low small pulses all right let's
go
I shoulda be the part get into a
comfortable squat position and let's go
push up with a Hughes okay
halfway there that's 20
oh it's burning last ten nine eight
seven six five four three two one give
you sighs a good message you have one
more workout one more workout it's going
to be a combination of squat to lunch
all right
Oh everything without take a few deep
breath see a sweat dripping one last
workout squat to lunch okay so let's
start with the left leg back ready squat
and lunch working on your right side
good find a workout guys you got this
you have come this far you have 50
repetitions left let's go it's gonna
burn I didn't say it's gonna be easy I
told you your legs who will be on fire
okay keep going
Oh feel that burn up down up and down
that's ten nine keep pushing your last
push eight seven six
oh my god five four
three to see the space one in pain okay
okay
the right side has done well now it's
the last night
all right check it out your final 25
repetitions all right you guys let's not
waste time let's go down and back
I can for your burner just listen to
your breath
oh my gosh
keep pushing last hand guys shake it a
little bit if you need to
let's go 9 more 8 huh
it's a final countdown 7 6 5 count it
out loud
4 let's go 3 2 oh my gosh
one and done that was 1,000 squats and
lunges let me know in the comments below
if your legs your thighs and your glutes
are on fire be sure to lift the fire
emoji in the comments below and be sure
to share this video tag to friends to
challenge them to complete this workout
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more crazy workout challenges
nutrition tips and also healthy and
delicious meal perhaps I'll see you in
my next workout of video all the best